hello rejects Greg here with the lovely
talented man man Billy popular on the
snappy Chettiar and he's also has a
youtube account Instagram account
Facebook a musically account if you have
that I just heard about this we're gonna
watch from the awesome awesome YouTube
channel dark five when we don't do movie
related content one of the only things I
think like the only thing I truly enjoy
watching when it's not like movie
related content at all there's anything
about dark [ __ ] that's happened in the
world and Christmas is right around the
corner so what dude it's it's comedy
puts time for beer how are you plus
comes gradually yes this time people's
depression tragedy every time five
strangest theories about Santa Claus
from Christmas past present and future
as a bar mitzvah Jew because I'm about
to learn five new things Jewish no idea
you wouldn't you would have survived
yeah I had a bar mitzvah and everything
I went to Israel I had no idea I dude I
know all the deep conversations we've
had religion has not been any of our
discussion Oh crazy I immediately feel
like we have a major separation between
us now as we should do we have those
talking dark antique laws and tie like
dark Zelda Dark Link sarees a modern
version of Santa a great imposter that
has straps from what some believe is the
real meaning of Christmas find that guy
looks fringe biblical scholars insist
that the secular Santa Claus embrace
since the early eighteen hundreds maybe
more Antichrist than Saint whoa what
attempts have been made to link the
current Santa's origins to ancient pagan
rituals in Gaza Gaza Wow look at all of
these photos of the sketchiest theory
the warm lack of a creepy mall Santa may
be no better than outstretched arms of
an idol of Moloch whose Moloch some
demonic deity it sounds like Moloch is
said to have received the children of
man and listen to wishes for material
goods and prosperity that's not bad
that's a good demon right there I like
that demon do what thou willst Santa has
yet to devour the children in a fire
sacrifice to make their wishes come true
which is probably what Moloch your boy
probably did jump boy whoa no
okay I'm gonna Santa bought whoa I ever
even heard of that theory that Santa
Claus might have been originally like
more of an antichrist kind of aa thing I
grew up Catholic not Catholic anymore
but I did grow up Catholic is he more
you more prevalent in like Catholicism
yeah yeah it's on Jesus's birthday when
Santa delivers gifts that's what we were
talking but isn't the whole the tree and
the dude stealing cookies and leaving a
present that you hopefully asked for
isn't that a pagan holiday your guess is
better than mine I believe Jews know
more about this dude that just has so
many other things for like conspiracy
theories like what because I've seen
movies of like killer crazy Santa
so when you have that is kind of
shocking to me to fuel to because
there's that childhood that energy
Catholic child
I feel like inside I'm still at a
Catholic boy at heart
that's where's a belief but I feel
guilty over many things in my life
and when I hear of like demonic things I
go must be real like that's in my first
instinctual feeling so to hear that that
might be whoa
knows why not entertain that as a
possibility why not not why not I'm not
gonna have my kid believe in Santa and
if he is I'm gonna let him know it's the
devil and he choose to believe in that
does that Samaritan
then pay tens of thousands of dollars
yeah as you're shelling it over like it
was a game my dad let me be a Satanist I
was great Santa bought some robot with a
music change - are you ready to hear the
pitter-patter of these nightmares or
reindeer BOTS clawing across your roof
what I mean I'm in 100% 15 Boston
Dynamics fear of the future of Christmas
may belong to a new robot Santa Overlord
whoa who needs more human myths and
traditions we can build an army of
emotionless mechanical magnitude of
little helpers that sounds great
I love this already so much I'm on board
with this people don't need jobs the
under companies on selling vision of
Santa sleigh
so a matter of time for the man himself
is replaced so we might have a
mechanical robot Ronald McDonald body
version of the Cubbies team right a
robot is already was waiting to pick up
and deliver present what drove Terrell
punishments military gay robot Sam I
have in store for an audience
oh that's right - follow the lure he has
to spank the bad boys and girls oh he
gives them coal and spank them okay Anna
do you think we have
you've been an Austrian version that's
so [ __ ] weird they had footage like
they're really trying to build us yeah
they had backing on those little weird
Robo dogs where you can push him in they
they're they're almost accentuate like
you know don't write themselves why
though why do we need a Santa robot
commercialize it man so they can be like
[Music]
whoa I'm just thinking if you can build
robots we can do more than build the
Santa I mean like we can build a
terminator I don't want t 1000 3100 sir
how cool would that be I guess I just
need to be the fastest runner in the
group of people that's okay I think if
you're gonna build robots you know open
up a theme park like based in a Western
time or I mean they're doing that
already and it's like those sketchy
animals singing dances I've always
thought it'd be cool to have like
prostitute robots this is not really
that bad oh you're not doing anything
wrong at that but it's just like a human
flesh light at that point right yeah
it's like the birds in the bee BOTS
Dalek everyone wants a log there's a
sidewise perhaps the most grotesque ly
bizarre Santa s creature ever concede
the tier didn't dull is a dead Christmas
log with tio didn't don't uncle of
something all a piece of wood is part of
cattle and ecology and appears cold and
hungry on our family's doorstep
I've never seen this before what this is
so new to me what is happening should I
must feed the log wrapping a blanket to
keep it warm as only a well care for
laudible shares
presents huh like it poops them consist
a log will be placed in the family
fireplace in order to defecate as the
children pray cool ordered to defecate
[ __ ] yeah oops the presents tradition
says that it shouldn't have been good to
the tio it will poop candy while the yes
with sticks you get to see it happening
that's pretty impressive it will drop a
salt herring garlic or onion or urinates
by leaving a bowl of water
I might just switched my belief in lore
to this one yeah I wait prefer that over
say that I would hollow log with a face
on it
so in Spain cut Catalan that's that's
like northern Spain I think yes a hollow
log or they'd hollow it out yeah
put googly eyes on it and then say hey
kids first knob this is like all under
yeah you're old tradition second feed
and clothe little [ __ ] with fire [ __ ]
ooping a present I think it does I think
this Christmas everyone in this
apartment complex is gonna have a log
waiting outside their door from me and
I'm gonna be shouting at them to feed
the law eat your log hide your log
matter has to transfer from whatever the
hell you're putting in their bark and
has to be eaten and digested into
whatever train [ __ ] you wanted how
do you put candy in the in their log no
like imagine you put supposed to put it
in there first and then you burn it
right did you poop after it's dead yeah
it's a weird thing well I mean to humans
poop when they die
a pee I think it's everything it's just
a smorgasbord
I thought humans pee or poop when they
die we yeah you become a human Chloe
yeah yeah you're just a woman give birth
they tend to poop
that's why I'm not going to be in the
delivery room that's me the 13 sons of
Mountain dwelling trolls a 13 Yule Lads
supposedly visit Iceland and the nights
before Christmas do their traditions are
already weird
I'm already on board their intentions
throughout history are uncertain the
folklore suggests they're at best
thieves and at worst homicide just look
Santa
he'll depending on child's behavior
during the year the Yule Lads will leave
gifts or rotting potatoes cheese okay
okay
I'll give you that lads also sister
everyone looked their best for Christmas
and those without new clothes are fed to
Joe a good Torian Krampus r2j word
Krampus you'll Ken is a large and
vicious man-eating predator that stalks
the snow in the icelandic countryside
okay is that link to what we just read
it is believed that threats of death and
the jaws of the creature were used to a
very wolf farmers to work bastard kids
to be better no no no is to increase the
production of wireless Oh
what's your Travis will be number one
okay that's a good number one that's a
good number one
yes popular in America teasing us with
the tip of the list and now we get the
full Krampus yeah I just continue why
did I finish that fun so there's 13 of
them that are the Santa that encompassed
the Santa type okay then if you're bad
you get fed to a tiger a your cat to be
correct oh sorry
and the your cat reminds me of there's a
punchline here angry [ __ ] like women
who have teeth in their vaginas I see
the movie I've seen them I've seen I've
seen the scenes that portray that in the
movie yeah here's my first movie on oh
yeah like a new thing to be scared of
like thanks jaws I'm scared to go to
water thanks teeth now I'm never gonna
go near a female that's why going gays
the best solution people we're going
twice is that a new sip is that the only
robot identification like I identify
myself as toy fun guy toy fun boy I
think it's an act
yeah let's see what they have to say
about Krampus I actually know it I
actually missed a Krampus movie I
haven't seen it
after this it's gonna light a new fire
into my ass to go watch great I bet here
we go wait on us internet believed to be
fearsome relic from Alpine Europe's
pagan past Krampus is a half goat half
demon that emerges before Christmas
all right I've seen him in American dead
he is typically depicted as a
supernatural beast with thick hair large
horns a long flicking tongue and sharp
fangs he'd do well with the ladies my
friend is mention that large flicking
tongue Krampus is said to drag chains
that represent the binding of the devil
and carries branches to swat bad
children so he's got the teeth but he
just hits kids with bread yeah naughty
boys and girls were warned that Congress
will stuff them in his sack and carry
them to be eaten into underworld who
that is
that's gnarly it is customary to give
cramps a special shot of liquor or
Krampus schnapps the schnapps I want to
try some Krampus guys subscribe to dark
5 as soon as you can ok what's a Krampus
that is gonna be who I like it's real yo
yeah like up on the shelf like oh well
he's always watching it's no it's you'll
get yeah everyone knows that the coolest
stuff is dark stuff oh yeah so go a
Krampus man I'm gonna teach my kids
about who Krampus is why we got a few
you know serve Krampus nuts would be
dude like milk that mean there should be
a crossover movie with Santa versus
Krampus Krampus would win oh yeah I mean
let's think about I mean Santa's
overweight old good old forever yes
never been young Santa's never big dad
said there's an old man and he has like
elves that worked for him they could
just eat them or lick them away gone in
once wanna know why he has these giant
teeth you doesn't seem to use it yeah
what a waste little wait tongue it
doesn't use it either hey crab as if
you're listening first off I'm a good
boy I promise don't believe in second
dude use the teeth man use the teeth and
the tongue man use it dude you'd be less
stressed if you use that tongue a little
more oh my is that like a self play sort
of yeah it's like hey man if you can
reach it in Peachy I wanted it to rhyme
so bad
alright guys subscribe to dark five
subscribe to the real rejects if you
please and man Billy like I say is on
the snappa T chatters YouTube Instagram
musically
man Billy real on Twitter yeah yeah and
yeah and he's he's Jewish and that
that's just icing on top shout-out to
the Jews who watch this channel look I
am all of you and just so you know I
like Jewish girls that's a very specific
trait of mine that's good
I mean if they always wanna see growing
up out there they were very exotic
because they believe in Christ
yeah it's okay like the leather jacket
like the Fonz's grade-school hard right
now but every Jewish girl I'm throwing
up though like Jesus was a silly concept
and I'm you've just never been more
childlike oh my god the fact that we are